after much anticipation Netflix finally
dropped its stylized adaptation of the
Ithorian ish graphic novel cursed from
legendary Dark Knight creator Frank
Miller in his writing partner Tom
wheeler the first 10 episodes of this
magical drama follow NIM way the famous
Lady of the lake destined to present
Arthur with the legendary sword
Excalibur which he will use to unite the
British kingdoms at least that's how
it's supposed to go but by taking the
spotlight away from Arthur and Camelot
and fixing it firmly on NIM way and
sword season 1 of curse charts a very
different narrative course and we've
come to expect from a typical author Ian
tail and I claim it
as the sword of the first queen the
fairy queen the series like the graphic
novel that came before it is only in
Arthurian tale in the most nominal sense
all of the familiar names and elements
are there nin way Arthur I grain Morgana
Merlin King Uther Excalibur but they've
been completely mixed up jumbled and
radically reimagined all the alterations
to the accepted mythology may be true to
Miller and wheelers source material but
that doesn't make some of the series
plot movements any less confusing for
fans of Arthurian romance if the season
1 finale proved anything it's that
cursed is not your granddaddy's once and
future king
for those viewers still trying to make
heads or tails of NIM ways last stand on
episode 10 here's a breakdown of
everything that happened on the dramatic
final hour
cursed be warned spoilers ahead episode
10 begins with a pleasant moment for our
heroine the calm before the storm she
awakens in the arms of her young lover
Arthur the two have finally consummated
their season-long flirtation and just in
time since NIM Wei has agreed to turn
herself into the detestable King Uther
in exchange for the safety of her people
she's still the queen of the fav or at
least one more day and she's going to
make it count outside the city where nin
way and Arthur organized the terms of
their surrender King Arthur and the red
paladin's led by the sadistic father
Cardin wait impatiently for the Bey to
throw in the towel they have the
occupied city surrounded and overwhelmed
and have only offered terms tuned in way
to avoid a lengthy siege but there is
dissension within the enemy ranks
whereas Uther only wants to get his
grubby little hands on Excalibur
Cardon's paladin's maintain a zealous
hatred of the Fae and would like to see
every last one of them exterminated
Cardin proposes a fanciful public
execution of NIM way would you thirty
Klein's burning this terrorist would
surely have the same demoralizing effect
Luthor discovers his spine just in time
to stand up to Cardin and avoid making
him way a martyr the squirrely king of
the Britons has already poisoned his
mother to death an act of savagery that
he follows by ordering his men to run
Merlin through as well all that after
Merlin finally told who Thor he was
proud of him without any adults in the
room to advise a mood there agrees to
let the Fae escape North by ship
unharmed as long as NIM wait turns
herself in and surrenders the city NIM
Wei agrees but not before secretiy
Morgana out of the city with Excalibur
to prevent the magical sword from
falling into nefarious
hands the Fae folk head to the water
guided by Arthur once they get to the
shore and see the ships awaiting them
Arthur sends a message back to NIM way
by walk this is the signal that it's now
okay for her to turn herself into King
Uther obviously the jealous King is none
too pleased that NIM way has found a
loophole in their deal and turned
herself in without Excalibur as it turns
out who Thor was planning to betraying
him way all along he contracted with a
band of savage Norseman to slaughter all
the fail on the shore before they board
their escape ships we see this hopeless
assault take place as NIM way is
rendered two ethers custody here's where
things get bloody father Cardin who's
held Gawain the green knight in custody
for some time now finally does the deed
and kills him the revelation of his law
sends NIM way into a rage reawakening
her powers she makes a break from ethers
camp with the injured Merlin in tow but
the religious zealots are hot on her
heels led by the assassins sister iris
who is as creepy as she is deadly
iris is highly motivated to kill NIM way
since she's been told accomplishing that
task will elevate her to true ret
paladin status iris catches up to NIM
way and Merlin and feathers our heroine
with arrows NIM wave falls from the rock
bridge where she made her last stand and
tumbles into the swirling water below is
she dead it seems unlikely but the
episode ends before we find out
definitively that's not all we have to
digest while we're waiting for season
two however and what is likely the
biggest reveal of season one the series
most interesting antagonists the weeping
monk who can track and slaughter pay by
sense is revealed to be none other than
Lancelot
that's life
Lancelot is of course destined to become
Arthur's most powerful Knight as well as
his wife's boyfriend though so much has
changed from the original mythology here
that it's impossible to foretell if any
of this will go down as expected the
young Faye boy squirrel who's been
protected consistently by Lancelot is
revealed to be Percival another one of
Arthur's famous knights of the round
table and Gwaine the dead Green Knight
he might not be so dead either it all
adds up to a lot of question marks
heading into season 2 all 10 episodes of
cursed season 1 are currently streaming
on Netflix check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]